you do know it you're gonna be mrs.
black hammer did you tell my brothers
that little clown is dating my sister
oh man smart what is your blessing and
asking your sister to marry show me that
you worthy of her how am I supposed to
do that I'm gonna take you on a
ride-along today is your training day
all the new dealers in Atlanta are
getting supplied through Antonio Pope in
Miami you need to get me something on
this guy two days tops
sorry but grown-ups for speaking Ben
you're barely even a probationary
officer Oh James if you want to take him
to Miami you can so get a team together
and fix this you better get ready come
here man
all right no it's too soon your partner
is marrying your sister big talk sex cop
courney is the best wedding planner in
Atlanta so what you're going to do by
you the brothers-in-law just got to town
you say that again shoot you in the face
huggers need the contraband through the
port you're gonna help me get some hard
evidence all I am think I'm gonna give
up my money don't give me luck is he
hotter than you Tasha because not only
through his phone first name I came
across was call it who was calling it
what's her ringtone
then I played your ringtone that cost
absolutely nothing since you've been
here I've had a nightclub shooting 20
trespassing complaints and a frickin car
blew up I went in plant car bomb yeah
but we did the other stuff
your partner James we protect each other
are you nervous Bambi hey what a dish oh
thanks mantis even further distance we
should easily hide fish that is benign
carpenters Maciej to spinach ever adding
a sense